hello everyone and welcome back to the
first leg of the fide grand prix 2022 uh
the the series of tournaments with that
will decide the the final two
challengers uh for the next candidates
tournament uh it's levon arghan vs
avidit and it's quite an enjoyable game
featuring another one of your favorite
openings of course that is the nimzo
indian defense uh we've seen um uh quite
a lot of it in the uh in the tata still
that it just ended we've seen the early
a3 line which should you know just
completely destroyed black uh it's
considered a lesser move but uh black
didn't really figure how to play against
it it was not uh used for some time uh
but here levon will stick to the to the
traditional one and it's uh well just
gonna be a very interesting game so
let's dive straight into it we have d4
by levon knight to f6 by visit c4 e6 now
comes knight to c3 and bishop to b4 the
name so indian is on the board uh and
now in the tata steel we've seen a lot
of a3s but here uh just a normal e3 uh
we have castles by visited and now
bishop to d3 the so-called bishops
attack against the nimzo indian uh we
have d5 striking in the center and now
usually white just continues developing
with something like knight to f3 or even
the early a3 but here levon first trades
in the center c captures e captures and
now plays a3 and this is somewhat rarer
uh bishop back to d6 so in this line the
dark square bishop survives and now
queen to c2 putting pressure on that h7
pawn so at some point of it it might
might play h6 but that's also weakening
the position if you don't have to play
it maybe maybe you don't want to play it
so c6 adding another defender here and
now comes knight g to e2 there are some
games where knight to f3 was played but
knight g to e2 is a new move so already
as of move 9 we have a completely new
game
with it continues developing rook to e8
and the bishop to d2 we have b6
and levon castles here we have bishop to
a6 uh ready to trade off white's very
strong light square bishop and here
levon just plays king to h1
uh also interesting is just uh capturing
on a6 this can be played but uh king h1
was played because you constantly have
to worry about ideas like this and i'd
cap knight to g for checking out okay in
this line it doesn't work because white
can play king to g3 and let's say queen
g5 there's f4 and uh the black queen
cannot remain on the g file so this
would be just silly for black but uh
it's always useful to avoid such
trickery so king h1 first and now c5
with its strikes in the center uh we
have rook 8 to d1 and now g6 now you
don't have to worry about the h7 pawn
and also the knight on f6 can move uh
and here levon plays queen to b1 right
so
i guess it can be considered a
multi-purpose move as the bishop can now
be retreated to c2 but also you're just
preparing this b4 push and now vidit
isn't as convinced
of capturing on d3 because as g6 has
been played the queen bishop battery on
this diagonal isn't all that impressive
so that it just brings the bishop back
of course you want it on this long
diagonal and now knight to f4 an
excellent square for tonight putting a
lot of pressure on that d5 pawn and if
bishop captures on f4 we're just gonna
capture and it seems like you can win a
pawn here but after knight
it's not all that much for black you're
gonna win back the pawn here the double
pawns are very weak here uh not much to
look forward to uh so instead adjust
knight b to d7 and that it continues
developing and now f3
we are considering e4 at some point
grabbing more space in the center
knights to f8 shifting the knight over
to e6 to challenge the knight this way
and now finally b4 uh we have c captures
on d4 you have to do something because
the pawn is uh well attacked many times
c captures with e captures and only now
bishop captures an f4 and this is a very
interesting capture uh you should uh
we often say that you shouldn't really
capture something just for the sake of
capture so maybe developing is is is a
better way to go but here that it has a
clear plan of what he wants to do so he
gives up the bishop prepare but he will
also win back white's uh bishop pair
bishop captures an f4 and now knight to
h5 and you can't really just move the
bishop back for example bishop d2 we're
going to play queen h4 and now uh you
are
in some trouble here okay it's not lost
yet you can play king to g1
but it's um it's not very comfortable so
instead bishop to e5 and now visit plays
f6 and forces white to retreat to g3
where he will capture the bishop so
bishop g3 knight knight captures h
captures and what the video did here
is that he traded down into this
position where black has a messed up
king structure and also a double g pawn
so queen to c7 putting pressure on that
weakness and now knight to e2 lemon has
to defend this and rook to e3 a very
nice rook lift it's on a dark square you
can't reach with the bishop with the
knight for the moment that rook is the
remainder and the other rook is coming
to e8 so queen to a2 very nice as
well you're expecting rook to e8 so you
want to have this nice sufficiently
defended and also this might be an issue
for black at some point so here rook 8
to e8 and now queen to d2
putting pressure on this rook
so queen to d6 okay the rook is defended
but you know that can change very easily
uh we have queen to d6 uh and now comes
rook to c1 uh grabbing hold of the uh
open c file we have rook three back to
e7 uh and now bishop to b5 attacking the
rook on e8 we have rooked the c8 uh now
offering a rook trade and levon trades
here we have rook captures bishop
captures and now queen to f4 offering a
queen trade and what do you do here now
basically your options are queen to e6
and queen captures an f4 and now uh okay
uh your opponent has a messed up phone
structure so you definitely don't mind
uh trading queens uh but on the other
hand uh
queen to e6 also has its merits uh all
depends on how do you evaluate the
position that it decides that maybe it's
better to trade off the queens so knight
captures an e4 and the bishop to b7 now
defending this pawn here so if you look
at the position now uh okay the bishop
on b7 is stuck guarding the d5 pawn but
the light square bishop even though it
can move
around freely it doesn't really have any
targets this pawn is nicely defended uh
you're not in time to attack it black
will be able to defend it sufficiently
and well like i said they're just not
all that many targets so here players
just to do what you have to do when you
enter the end game they start improving
the position of their kings king to g1
king to f7 king to f2 and now knight to
e6 offering a night trade but this also
means that now very left his king side
unattended so here rook to h1
uh going after that h7 pawn so h5 and
now bishop back to d3 putting pressure
on the g6 pawn level one says all right
i don't mind if you capture here i'm
just gonna promote my double g pawn into
a doubled f pawn so here knight captures
on f4 g captures on f4 and now rook to
c7 and this rook to c7 is a problem move
for vidit uh he was very much low on the
clock here and here you have to play
something else but he played rook to c7
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out how to take advantage
of this and win the game for levon while
i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
cracking this end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show the
move is not g4 the move is actually f5
so congratulations to everyone who found
f5 hence uh not rook to c7 maybe f5 from
vidit would have been better here but
for those of you who consider the g4
because you saw kh captures g rook h7
check picks up the rook there's a
problem rook to c3 and now it's uh well
not all that great king e2 we defend our
bishop bishop to c8 now and after g
captures captures and captures we
capture on a3 white row captures on d5
we're gonna play rook a2 check and after
king e3 rook a3 uh with some ideas of
maybe bishop the a6 if the if the rook
moves the fifth rank but as long as the
rook is on the fifth rank if bishop a6
just b5 this is perfectly fine
uh so uh okay after this uh rook to c7
like we said f5 was played once again uh
congratulations to everyone who who
decided for this movie because now uh
there's no way to prevent material loss
uh here i will try the g5 but just to
show you what happens if captures we're
going to capture with the rook now this
pawn is attacked twice and if you try
kink the g6 to attack the rook and
defend the pawn then g4 and that's it uh
the the f1 is pinned there's no no
playing this if bishop c8 we just go
into the same game bishop captures
bishop captures rook captures now this
pawn will fall too and yes okay black
has some counter play with rook to c3
king g3 rook captures on a3 rook
captures here but now you have a past d
pawn and also you will create a pass
pawn on the king side black will not be
able to fend over the two weaknesses so
after f5
uh with it try to g5 okay at least he
will keep his uh pawn structure intact
for the price of a pawn rook captures an
h5 and now king to g7 uh we have rook
back to h1 by levon and now rook to c3
we have king to e2 and now okay if you
capture on a3 which you can and then
rook to c1 is very ugly there's just no
good way to handle this for example if
bishop a6 you offer a trade rook c7
check uh we we deliver one check and
after the king moves just b5 for example
traps the bishop but any other line is
is terrible for black so here bishop the
c6 first by bit it now comes rook to a1
level on defense his spawn although even
b5 and a4 was was okay bishop to d7 and
now king to d2 now the rook is forced
away from the third rank rook to c8 and
now b5 uh
grabbing more space on the queen side
rook to h8 but it's not a problem just
g4 the rook really has nothing to do
here on
on these files uh so rook back to c8 and
now we have a4 so okay you grabbed a lot
of space here you you've improved your
position but how do you actually uh go
from this to winning this position it's
only you're only up one pawn and it's a
doubled f pawn well king to f8 and now
comes a5 now we uh trade off here and we
activate our rook that's how we do it so
king e7 a captures a captures and rook
to a7 we have rook to b8 making sure
that no
no harm can come to this b6 pawn now
king e3 we have king to d6 and now levon
uh strikes with f4 so this is uh now
creating a second weakness rook to e8
check king to f3 g captures an f4 king
captures on f4 and now uh the thing is
the the the position is uh
very passive for black for example if
rook to b8 you don't want to allow some
like rook b7 we're just going to improve
our position as much as possible before
we play g5 for example rook a6 puts
constant pressure on this pawn at some
point we play g5 uh once our position is
as good as it can be and then we we just
win the game so here that it saw that uh
passive play is not the way to play this
he tried uh one last trump card and this
this is a well it's not not really a
trump card but it's uh a
a very good idea and it really shows you
how you
always have to look for that little
something
no matter how bleak the position seems
uh bishop captures on b5 he gives up the
bishop bishop captures here and now rook
to e4 check seemingly going for the d4
pawn but after king f3 rook f4 check
vidit offers a rook here and of course
the rule cannot be accepted as the black
king would now be in stalemate so that's
the that's the trick here so levon has
to figure out how to avoid the checks
otherwise uh he just stalemates black
and it's a draw so king e3 that it
continues rookie for check king f2 we
have rook to f4 check and now king to e1
and now after check
we can block with bishop to e2 so here
that it captures the pawn uh we have
rook to a4 you can't allow these two
pawns to disappear off the board
otherwise it's going to be a draw uh so
not much to do here rook captures on a4
was played bishop capture is now king e5
hoping to eliminate these pawns so king
d2 king f4 and now of course bishop to
d1 we will not allow it d4 now comes
king to d3 attacking the pawn king e5 we
have defending the pawn king c4 and now
king the e4 bishop c to check king the
e3 and bishop to b1 and with this bishop
to b1 move it was on move 64 that vidit
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here but it's a a
beautiful continuation and for those of
you who are maybe new to chess would be
like yes but how do you how do you
actually win this uh well it's also very
enjoyable for example if black tries b5
and there's really not all that much to
try b5 check king here d3 yes white will
also have to give up the bishop but
after captures captures there's g5 f
captures on g5 f6 g4 f7 g3 and now white
gets a queen into the game and that's
just it you are not in time if g2 a
simple queen f2 can pick up the pawn uh
if the black king was closer then yes it
would be dangerous for example if the
black king was uh
one square closer to the pawn but we
know that even here it would still be
winning because uh you guys by studying
the end game so vigorously know that if
the pawn is here here here or here then
it's a draw and of course if the pawn is
here here here or here then it's a win
but yeah i don't have to tell that to
you guys uh so yeah after bishop to b1
village resigned and a wonderful start
uh to the grand prix for lebon arenan
who is one step closer to qualifying for
the fedex candidates tournament uh
in the next cycle uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it always
fight until the very end like vidi did
here because you never know when it uh
you know it could work uh i would like
to wish a very happy birthday to uh
rohan chaudhary and i would like to
thank mr hoody guy mr hoodie guy mr
hoodie guy and mr hoodie guy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video grand prix until it ends thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day